right now the Democrats have a very very
very slim majority of control right they
don't technically have the Senate but
the tiebreaker goes to the Democrats so
they do have that power but they can't
break the filibuster yep so not only
that they have to convince Mansion of
everything and he's a West Virginia
Democrat so it's hard for them to move
they do have the house and there have
been Republican defectors like on the
January 6th commission so they do have
that yeah however it seems like things
are really bad yeah you know uh so
they're saying but inflation is going to
make everyone's wages go I read this
article they were like don't be scared
of inflation it means your wage will go
up and I'm like wow preying on the
ignorance your wage will go up after the
cost of everything else goes up and your
savings is decimated it's a tax on
everybody and then right this is what's
funny about Joe Biden saying no no you
make less than 400 000 you know not a
penny in taxes Medicare so he says that
but what what and then all these you
know Lefty socialists say see he's not
taxing us and then he goes I'm gonna
print six trillion dollars yeah and and
that is a tax on all of these people
he's he's taking your savings by
printing this money yep the value of
your money goes down yes so yeah your
wage will go up after the fact after
they've taken your savings through
indirect means yeah and a lot of people
uh they don't realize it so because of
these things we've uh so let me let me
just let me just list some uh some
problems with the Democrats right now
yeah I I I'm I self-reflect I'm looking
at all the Biden stuff and I'm like do I
have Biden derangement syndrome like was
I just tribalistically like Trump's not
that bad right now Biden's and I just
Biden's bad okay I've tried to give
Biden credit on things you know uh he
sped up the vaccine roll out and I was
like you know okay if he's increasing
the timeline it's working I'll say it's
a good thing right if it's an
improvement because I try to I want to
make sure I'm not just screeching it
however he reopened the homestead
facility which is the migrant children
expanding the McAllen facility kids are
sleeping in dirt now I'm not going to
blame him for these kids because but he
is also the guy who ended Trump's remain
in Mexico policy which is causing the
pull factor he's now smuggling children
his administration in the dead of night
to other states you've got the policy in
Syria the missile strikes the the
movement of soldiers the funding of
groups with Israel and Palestine just
exacerbating everything a breakdown of
Middle Eastern relations
hyperinflation the unemployment benefits
the mass spending of money and I'm like
man this guy really is torching
everything yeah so maybe yeah it will be
enough that come 2022 people vote for
the America First Republicans because
I'll say two things
um first
maybe a lot of people are disillusioned
by the whole system and are going to
walk away yeah but maybe that will
inspire a bunch of
non-traditional Republicans to Ron
probably like you to be like America
first let's fix this country let's do
better because I'm not a fan of the
Republican party no neither am I and I
think a big mistake that Republicans
could make is think that they can stop
the America first movement because if
they go and they throw their money
behind traditional candidates the base
that got Trump his victory they're just
not going to come out and vote there
it'd be a huge mistake for the
Republicans to make this make the
mistake to think that people are loyal
to the Republican party like they're not
they're loyal to Trump they were loyal
to America First and it wasn't just
Trump I mean there were some people who
were you know they they love Trump and I
like the guy a lot too and I think he
was a great president but it's not about
a cult of personality it's about the set
of values that he put forward and I
think if the Republican party doesn't
fully Embrace those they're going to get
taken over by America First eventually
but they could really screw up in this
this critical period that we're at right
now there are a lot of people that you
you know live and die by Trump they
scream Trump they love Trump they have
Trump flags and there are a lot of
people who voted for him who are like
well he believes in this country it's
the best we got exactly yeah and he's
willing to fight back against the
permanent ruling class like if you just
have a career politician go in there
have we picked anybody else that was on
that stage in 2016 it would have been
the continuation of the Bush Obama era
and the uniparty yeah how how amazing is
it that uh like how many countries on
the planet are their own country second
you know what I mean exactly yeah right
so so it's funny how the idea of America
First gets smeared and I'm confused by
that right it's also how they smeared
the idea of populism I was always
confused by that I remember when it
first came out and they were like these
populists are bad and it's dangerous and
I was like what are they what are they
trying to say I'm confused what do they
mean by that right and then I'm like
wait are they literally saying the will
of the people is bad like when these
people are are having a Democrat a
democratic election in their
constitutional republic it's not a good
thing and the elites should be in charge
by virtue of them being Elites yes
that's literally what they were saying
it was very it was confusing to me and
then I was like oh oh wait wait they
literally mean popular they mean like
the regular people are like hey this is
how we want things to be wrong I think
there's certainly some arguments in that
you know we criticize the Democrats
because they're trying to get everyone
possibly to vote right so they want 16
year olds voting who have no political
experience so certainly in that respect
okay I can understand the argument but
I'm still not going to vote for a Wall
Street Banker by virtue of him being
rich exactly that's the most ridiculous
idea ever so you get Trump but now
you're now you start you're starting to
see more and more politicians who are
like we're gonna do right by America
then we can focus on everything else
what's amazing to me is you get on a
plane You're Gonna Play what do they say
secure your own face mask before
securing the face mask yeah mask of
those next to you and we're in a country
that during a pandemic when our
businesses were locked down the Omnibus
spending bill was sending tax dollars to
other countries yeah
that is insane billion that that was it
was more than billions of trillions yeah
I mean we had 12 million to like
Pakistani gender studies yeah how does
that I would rather give 12 random
Americans 12 million dollars than send
it overseas because at least it'll stay
in in the economy 100 yeah but it's
because of the Petro dollar because they
want these other countries using the
dollar to maintain that that system and
those dollars make their way back into
politicians Pockets through Lobby yeah
some special interests and super Pacs
and like it's a whole fixed system and
you know and it's not serving the
American people I'm I'm
you know I talk about living in the pot
and eating the bugs and all that stuff
I've got no problem I said this all the
time if I get banned you know I'm gonna
do I'm gonna get in my van drive down to
the river and go fishing just mind my
own business I am very happy to just be
sitting there every day looking up the
stars and a little tent get a dog or
whatever I don't need much to be happy
and I think about America First and the
idea to me well sounds like a lot of
hard work a lot of people are going to
be doing a lot of hard work to support
themselves I think it sounds really good
for the environment because what the
current system you know how insane the
current system is skateboards I
mentioned this several times you want to
get a skateboard in the United States
here's what they do they chop a tree
down in Canada send it to China turn
into a skateboard sent to California
yeah with all these tariffs why do that
that's terrible for the inside why not
just have a guy in you know in in
Pacific Northwest cut down a tree get
into a skateboard and then you put on a
truck and send it to you yeah exactly
waste so
when I when I hear about this idea of
like bring the factories back get
Americans back to work we'll be working
we probably won't be the biggest name
you know in the wealthiest in the planet
you're not going to have 12 new iPhones
every year but you're going to have what
you need you're going to be responsible
for what you produce you're going to be
happy with it yep instead we know we
have the opposite we have entitlement
people who just get yeah they they want
stimulus checks they want they live in
big cities they work at BuzzFeed where
they pay tons of money to write articles
about nonsense yep I'm not a fan I
really see this fourth turning in effect
um are you familiar with the fourth
turning and how like every generation
people become distance from the past you
know that people don't they're so soft
that they don't that they have this this
I don't know air of like assumption or
this like belief like they're owed
things and and peace and prosperity and
like that that doesn't that doesn't like
accidentally happen that's right yeah
they're they're they're they're it's
been ingrained
look
when I when I'm sorry I I have a story
about my buddy started a company
he was trying to hire people he kept
hiring college grants I'll give you the
short version and they kept screwing up
and he was like I went through you know
hire two people they screwed up I hired
two more people they screwed up I hired
two more people I'm like I can't afford
to keep doing this these people can't do
the job so then finally he hired some
some High School uh High School dropouts
yeah I got like the geds or something
but they hadn't moved from I think like
Utah to California or Iowa to become
actors and he said these guys were
perfect and then he realized
they took the initiative to leave where
they live to go seek you know their
witches and their adventure and they
were self-starters when he went to
people who were at what college degrees
what he found was these are people who
just did what they were told so they
couldn't solve any problems when a
problem was presented and then he
realized like not only do I save money
but these people are more capable
I see these people going to college not
because they're pursuing a passion but
because they were told they told you yep
so now for me it's like it's I typically
look for I don't care if you have a
degree or not I care if you have a
portfolio you're passionate and you can
prove it yeah exactly I think the uh
the what happened with the greatest
generation was they went through so much
hardship and so much adversity in the
war they fought it collectively together
they all fought so much that they didn't
need to come home and talk about it and
dwell on it but they also had stuff to
do we had this whole production industry
while the war was going on because we
had to have it and then Americans just
fell in on that production industry went
to work and built the country that we
had and I think that the byproduct of
that was the Boomers and the Boomers had
this horrible experience with foreign
intervention in Vietnam and so if you
didn't want to go to Vietnam what'd you
do he went to college and so this whole
industry got produced around hey like
all the smart kids go to college the
dumb kids joined the military kind of
spitting in the face a little bit of
rebellion too at the Boomers who uh not
that was the greatest Generation who
took service very very seriously
um and so now the byproduct of that is
we have there's no Collective identity
of Americans we didn't collectively all
go through something you know and then
you throw in the whole College aspect
too where the Divide is now class the
people that were smart enough to go to
college to really learn how to follow
instructions properly and get
indoctrinated because the leftists
infiltrated the colleges a long time ago
and then the rest of the country who
their those production jobs they all got
killed so they're disenfranchised then
you have the opioid epidemic and you
have all these guys these young men just
looking for for purpose I think a lot of
these City dwelling college educated
individuals don't realize that what they
do only exists because of the rural
labor market the farmers particularly
right people who work in agriculture
it's really incredible how that is the
backbone of this country I mean there's
no food without these people so you can
you want to work in a lab you want to
work in a university get your Grant well
your Grant only works because you can go
and buy food because someone made that
food yeah they don't get it so what
happens is we have this system people go
to college they say going to college is
your ticket to a better a better future
they tell their kids they'll get a
better job just get a degree yeah just
get a degree whatever it is anything and
now these kids have you know art liberal
arts degrees Follow Your Passion
philosophy you know I believe it or not
people do get degrees in folklore and
mythology sure yeah but what are you
going to do to sustain the system other
you know nothing yeah these degrees
don't do anything so you end up with a
lot of people who have a lot of useless
degrees many who have changed their
majors
but still demand higher salaries because
they've they think they're entitled to
it they did what they were yeah exactly
I did what I was told I deserve it give
it to me now here's the best part these
these kids who are all graduating and
the adults the millennial adults nearing
their 40s who have this massive debt are
now the highest income earners in the
country demanding the working class pay
their debts off yeah that's right is
this like how often does that happen in
history where the ultra Rich demand the
poor I shouldn't say Ultra rich but
where the wealthier causes yeah demands
the government tax the poor to pay off
their debts no there's it's a recipe for
disaster is there going to be a Revolt
or or the Working Class People gonna
step up and be like I am not paying your
debts you met your salary these some of
these people they get jobs at 50 Grand a
year to write articles for BuzzFeed
right there are people that BuzzFeed who
make sex figures they do really really
well I mean it's a legit company they
make a lot of stuff but how is it that
you can write you know three or four
articles per day about whatever nonsense
here's a little here's a picture of a
bunch of cats and you'll get paid more
money than a guy who's fixing your sewer
yeah that to me is incredible and that's
a problem with our economy I've always
felt this way since I was a kid you know
I always thought like why is it that
baseball players get paid more than
doctors yeah you know shouldn't doctors
get paid a lot more right well whatever
your opinion on that I'm sure a lot of
people say well the marketplace well
here we go right now you have people who
are dredging through sewers pulling out
Rat Kings you know what a rat king is
when all the rats get stuck together and
they clog pipes and you pull them out
their tails are all tied in nuts yeah
there are people have to put on I knew a
guy growing up his his uh his stepdad
would put on a full body suit and go
into five feet of sewage and be trying
to stick their hand in and clear out
pipes and there's needles and stuff and
and that that person gets paid less yeah
than some 24 year old degree sitting in
an office in New York writing articles
about like here's five pictures of
hamsters that'll make you laugh yeah
that system to me makes no sense and
will be unsustainable once the working
class the labor actually realizes that
they're getting paid less being rewarded
less for their hard work and sacrifice
yeah and not only that service members I
think that's what terrifies the
authoritarian left so much about America
first because we've become the party of
the working class and the party in the
middle class we're the ones that say hey
we want people to have a job we want
them to have their dignity and their
individual sovereignty I think that that
terrifies the left because they're
seeing that Awakening that's what was
that's what actually was so dangerous
about Donald Trump because Trump was
like I can make your guys's wages rise I
can put our country first you don't need
to play with this you don't need to play
by this system that has done absolutely
nothing but failure and that's why I
think you've seen the left shift their
their focus so much to all these racial
issues and the critical race Theory
because anytime they want to saddle us
with more debt or do job-killing
economic policies they have to they have
to distract from that and they have to
they have to keep the races fighting how
do you how do you convince somebody who
works at BuzzFeed for Hi-Fi figures that
they're actually worse off than the
construction worker making 25 an hour
how do you how do you convince them oh
race you make it about race and
intersectionality yep and so there you
go they've redefined the conflict so
that they can keep people voting for
them convinced they're the saviors when
in reality these New York you know
liberal types who are in their 20s man
I'll tell you when I first walked into
that Vice building I started working at
Vice and the job I had before that I was
working in non-profits and I was getting
a like base like base salary before that
I used to work at O'Hare Airport and I
was loading bags yeah 10 bucks an hour
eventually made 11 bucks an hour lifting
about 50 000 pounds per day to load
these planes and it was hard work and
people got hurt and yeah in order to pay
for their their their families to fund
their family so people work double
shifts all day every day and then I walk
in device and I see these people just
like sitting back they got like booze on
their on their on their table they got
whiskey they're drinking and I'm like
what are you guys doing like chilling
and I'm like you're getting paid like
fifty thousand dollars a year not all of
them advice didn't notoriously paid not
that well but a lot of these people are
getting like 35 to 50 and they were
doing nothing yeah relatively nothing
they did something you know they'd get
emails from people saying here's a story
and they'd be like cool and they'd take
it and then they'd put it on the site
and like some people wouldn't even show
up for work and I'm like so it it's true
man you moved to New York City you can
get a do-nothing job that pays really
really well how long until the people
who are actually doing the labor that
supports this country how long until
they say hey wait a minute why am I
making stuff for you and you don't do
anything
there is an issue I suppose because
people say hey the market pays or the
Market's going to pay
but then you look at how the policies of
of the left are are functioning today
Joe Biden's just taxing the working
class that's right through inflation
which and then giving money to people in
cities who aren't working yeah at a
certain point people are going to say
nah yes once they get start getting
hungry for sure I think when the
technology is like broad enough that you
can communicate you can establish like
pockets of resistance for the workers to
defy like the white collar oligarchy but
we need to figure out a system that
solves for that because throughout time
the workers have been rising up and
overthrowing the government and creating
a revolution but then they become the
new oligarchy and then produce another
form of tyranny that another group of
workers have to rise up and overthrow so
like building a decentralized system
where yep there's no oligarchy I think
that's the that's got to be the only way
yeah I think getting rid of our
political classes is the key because we
we can we can vote we have elections we
should be able to do this but we've just
Fallen this two-party system and the two
parties have just pretty much done the
same thing which is screw over the
working class so that's why I mean I
think you saw the establishment on both
sides left and right go after a guy so
heavily like Donald Trump you know
because if imagine if there was more
Donald Trump like that we could disrupt
the entire system and really put it back
on a footing where the Working Class
People actually had had a chance thanks
for checking out this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to see
the full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time